on était parti pour marseille
je dormais à l'aéroport
tu es à la boutique et j'ai vu ce
collier
était en or et c'était crystal waters
je me suis dit que ce serait un petit
bout de pays que tu emporterait
[Musique]
ça
vous êtes à marseille pour les vacances
je suis venu voir mes filles
[Musique]
vous êtes le père de la fille étudiante
amérique
exactement
allison était venu ici pour ses études
et à la rencontre et cette fille il a un
soir à la retrouver lina morte et elle a
appelé la police le seul truc qui les
intéressait c qu'alison couché avec une
arabe
puisque les mais oui je serai tout le
monde pense que je les tue
nous avons épuisé tous les recours mais
l'avocate ne vous êtes pas c'est moi qui
m'en occupe pour l'instant tu peux vous
aider
comment tu t'appelles maya maya c'est
joli
elle est très protectrice avec moi
vous avez déjà vu ce garçon personne ne
vous parlera croyez moi
vous n'êtes pas d'ici c'est dangereux
pour moi
c'est ma gamine hama
je la laisserai pas tomber
[Musique]
je serait une grave erreur de commettre
un crime pour prouver l'innocence de
votre fille ça ne l'a sortira pas de
prison
et ça vous et on verra
s'il te plaît seigneur veille sur alison
amen
trop lisse il y avait demandé de mentir
je veux sortir ma gamine de tôle le
reste j'en ai rien à [ __ ] vous parlez
vraiment comme un américain là tant
mieux j'en suis un oui et vous êtes
aussi un étranger
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as fait
tu dois faire confiance